[Music]
yeah distracting
okay well let me let me do it in between
your words that's a good compromise
that's really do it now it's practicing
three want you to count his wouldn't
count he wants Lauren I was practicing
so you got ready when you start going in
whatever knew he said I love you but he
said so clearly words not numbers go in
super scam is submitted by jazz hands
a man scammed his friends and family out
of 150 grand
oh man I got to do that I know why they
did that they're trying to buy a house
in LA down of money I know let the stars
well it's a good down payment yes oh
this story here kind of [ __ ] up so
this dude his name is kitten kitten
captain like kitten like the cat yeah
Catan it's a ke t 8n Kenton I wish she
just [ __ ] it's a ki t Tem yeah
thinking with the a here we [ __ ] go
yeah Keaton NIT okay yeah keep see but
this isn't that oh yeah guitar this
one's bad and that one's this anyway
your last name is hahaha
it doesn't matter
you know I struggle with pronouncing and
reading in every shop just for that sake
JW anyway so this takes place in Atlanta
he's a businessman who scammed so many
people what an [ __ ] he was saying
that he had tickets to the Super Bowl
oh really yeah that's a fire festival
scam that is a possible move yes
tickets to so many people but obviously
he didn't have them so they paid him he
doesn't give you tickets there's no like
in person not in person it was uh like
he would send them a fake contrary to
your code bullshitting or not accurate
like an actual like letter saying like
you paid me this I'm gonna give you this
mmm like but like it's printed like on
like a word doc you know anymore Jesus
yeah that's a binding contract though
mm-hm
a contract written on a napkin is a
binding contract if two people assign a
grade 2 and plus they knew him in the
community and he has a whole family and
everything oh yeah
that'll mean [ __ ] yeah but he'll I just
took off he took off and he did all the
money and ran yeah he collected all the
money ran no he thought up in the hall
the other people are board up in there
was duped yeah what if you ripped off
Patriots fans it's actually ok that's it
so it's ok it's actually watch who are
you rooting for
no it's Patriots are ramps Rams ok why
just by default if you live in LA
because I'm a Colts fan I [ __ ] hate
the Patriots
oh good you had to know that they
weren't gonna win this year did I have
to know that cuz everyone said that last
year about the Eagles dude everyone
thought the Eagles is gonna get crushed
last year so just saying Eagles won last
feels well nice to beat the Patriots
I don't know football but then this year
you know obviously sucked ass because
their safety first now yeah exactly
mm-hmm yeah so one victim paid him
$500,000 oh my god 2
host a Super Bowl party at an arena
another victim paid $50,000 for two
tickets on the 50-yard line see rich
people are just as stupid as poor people
true it's like these two friends they
had saved up money for a long time and
paid I think it was $15,000 what a lot
of these people do though is the groom
you or they're already in like they're
not he's not a stranger right yeah so if
he's not a stranger then it's kind of
it's just [ __ ] up like there it
doesn't make any sense why he can't do
it damn what did the mom do to him she
why are they all ballin disheartened he
scampers mom amount of 75k like what the
[ __ ] no he also took out it alone on his
house and his wife didn't know about it
Oh everyone this guy's crazy Wow where
did he go I think he ran away yes so
here's why I said that he had this like
midlife crisis and he ran off to Vegas
he he was gone so she reported him
missing but then he came back a few
weeks later but then this time he was
gone and he he was gone gone he was gone
gone for four weeks he's like she said
that he had never been gone this long he
usually goes on for two weeks he had
like crisis for two weeks yeah so
detectives were investigating if he went
to Miami Oklahoma Alabama New Mexico
Arizona Las Vegas Alaska Hawaii Missouri
North Dakota South Dakota New York nice
Beach Boys on Illinois Indiana Ohio New
Hampshire Vermont oh my god yes my
Florida doll if you slow down just a
Johnny Cash song just saying states no
no take your car so
California no bad strings these cute
little I don't want to do it when you
tell me to do it do dishes and I'm like
I love and then she's like what are you
gonna do it and I'm like well I do but I
just [ __ ] do it
then I'm her [ __ ] but if I do it ten
minutes later I'm somehow not her much
some dishes got done regardless so
you're still her [ __ ] right but then
sometimes I've done it a little too long
where I'm like it's been two days and
I'm I said I would do it yeah I'll do a
blouse before you're married I don't do
it you only have good days I was just
trying to see how far I could stretch
the rubber band before it broke
I broke twenty rubber bands anymore only
good good days now my man I don't do
that on purpose I just forget I know I
know as she raises a cigarette to her
about it looks into the distance with a
flask silver flask and the other hat but
anyways we have a casino worker in
Riverside this casino worker recognized
this man from all these TV networks
reporting on the story and so they they
told the Riverside County Sheriff's
Department and then they confirmed that
he was at Pechanga casino resort as a
baller dude yes [ __ ] [ __ ] anga and
the river sexy okay so you rob people
for 200k 50k 75k with a million right
he's one of Pechanga well well he
probably you know where I'd go is this
ascent is the [ __ ] Century City
casino what is that Century City are you
talking about Hollywood Park yeah yeah
that one there's a race like a horse
racetrack that you know that was in
Hawaiian Gardens the city called one
no but the casinos the Hawaiian Gardens
is annoying I'm going with the one you
pass it on the freeway when you're going
on the one-on-one please change the
channel it's a guy stand is family free
free wheel video some pasties Leigh
Logan Paul arrested or whatever and then
and then the next one you know he says
like Star Trek jelly beans oh yeah so
this guy was caught because you know the
casino worker that casino worker got
fired
how can you [ __ ] take away one of our
most loved it customers love it I know
do you imagine being a high roller in
one of those casinos oh that's amazing
doesn't take much no although like old
ladies that are like kind of little
saggy and you know they're coming up to
you like hey baby
hey I played poker in one of those
casinos that's where I met Dante Basco
Oh mm yeah and then there was a bully
ass old grandma every time she went she
was nice and every time she lost she was
really mean to everybody so everyone
would just wanted her to win a little
so she's not doing me dude I love that
I'm perfect I'm lucky took her money
about sitting at a slop thing and they
have the cigarette up here and they take
they pull the handle down with the
cigarette and ash Falls I don't know
they still have those you can pull it
just the money then yeah I wonder what
those ladies do for a living they're
retired they're on disability look like
they work at CVS they look like that
they look like they volunteer at the
library or work at a CVS I think in
Walmart and in old guys the old guys are
the greeters at the Walmart yeah yeah oh
I never sent you a photo of them
cameraman Susie charts Oh [ __ ]
indium guy yep I know I would never pick
him up out in the lineup yeah I was
thinking about like a senior citizen
Vietnamese dude no he's a Shannon he's
the devil
yeah and it's [ __ ] up two cousins
family the wife had like a breakdown
when she found she found out that he did
this and so she had to go to the
hospital and then the family has just
been been harassed pretty much by the
media and then all these people they
might even think that there's like in
Kahoot
I don't think his name is Keaton anymore
that's why I was like watch let us say
Keaton if you knew that you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] shock us oh you're gonna
interrupt my [ __ ] story time now you
gonna look stupid oh it's Keaton yeah
King mcfarley but I spelled it out for
you just gotta buy some cheap suits -
Velma I hope he writes that wrinkle I
didn't even look at the suit I looked at
his shady face this is like crime Life
of Pi I want to know what happened on
his adventure for weeks
yeah they say what he does for a living
yeah so this is he scams people yeah he
has a family business like a printing
it's a scam officer scam officer yeah
he's also a scam off is it printing
money
it's
so bad that I really honestly don't care
because they're Patriots fans that
that's how I know I've taken it all too
far
Wow really yeah I just don't feel any
like guilt Ernie hey I'm a Patriots fan
you don't like me anymore you're not
yeah yeah no you're not yeah yeah well
you didn't even say [ __ ] about the game
or nothing I was just so happy that my
boy Brady like no other players in Tom
Brady Tom Brady yeah [ __ ] six rings
baby yeah just one other player in
toppers pony to because he went to
Disneyland and that's all I cared about
huge fan yeah and his wife is hot hot
yeah what's her name Gisele Bundchen
what's her last name
Brady Bunch in Brady